Argentine Ukraine Lituanie Allemagne
Royaume-Uni c'est la rentrée pour ses
étudiants à l'université de Versailles
Saint-Quentin certains resteront un
semestre d'autres une année les
étudiants qu'on viennent d'accueillir ce
sont des étudiants qui viennent dans le
cadre de programme d'échange c'està-dire
des des échanges avec des universités
qui sont partenaires de l'UVSQ les
autres étudiants étrangers viennent
s'inscrire dans des diplômes soit 95
nouveau venus sur 2400 étudiants
étrangers choix des cours cartes
d'étudiant assur maladie l'installation
peut vite se transformer en un parcours
du combattant à commencé par la
recherche d'un logement ça difficile je
en train de trouver un colog une chambre
je sais pas mais c'est difficile pour
moi les difficultés parfois c'est la
langue parce que parfois leur niveau de
français est insuffisant pour pouvoir
suivre les cours qui sont donnés en
français pour la majorité des cas après
la difficulté majeure c'est le logement
pas se cacher qu'il y a quand même
quelques difficultés pour les étudiants
à trouver logement de la même façon que
pour les étudiants français d'ailleurs
mais bon on a un service de logement qui
est très actif qui est qui a été ouvert
il y a pas très très longtemps donc qui
les aide un maximum comme vous l'avez vu
on a distribué une liste pour les
étudiants qui seront en difficulté
encore aujourd'hui pour trouver un
logement l'université de Versailles
Saint-Quentin compte 18000 étudiants et
près de 1400 enseignants chercheurs elle
a passé 230 accords de partenariat avec
des universités à travers le
mondeire la